alors j'en ai un ami vous savez que etc
minus et savoir gérer des catastrophes
vous n'avez jamais beaucoup la vache
folle l'erika et cetera
donc on va vous faire une interview
catastrophe on ne bouge pas pendant le
boulch pam on ne bouge pas pendant le
temps le bouchon ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle
il ya un hit baffie cela mais votre fils
a volé chez vous un tableau votre
tableau préféré pour s'acheter de la cam
vous fait quoi si une catastrophe
charade tout j'arrête la politique et je
m'occupe de lui ah ouais ouais vous dit
s'il en est arrivé là c'est que je m'en
occupe pas assez de vivre est l'objet
d'autres qui disent façon d'autres qui
se défoncent avec la cam du fils vous
non pas du tout pendant les vacances de
temps famille de teint bon papa vous
retrouvez seul un jour comme ça dans la
maison avec votre belle mère et votre
belle-mère fou ou fait des avances
faites quoi
assange l'esprit gens bien sûr est bien
possible mais impossible de pour
impossible impossible
enfin impossible que je réponde à ces
avancées impossible bon impossible
ouais je suis incapable 1 si moche que
ça vous draguer une fille sublime vous
la ramenez chez vous un peu comme dans
joyeuses pâques la pièce d'arditi et
votre femme est pas là vous découvrez
que c'est un travelo vous faites quoi je
fais quoi machine arrière
[Applaudissements]
bonne fille vous annonce qu'elle va se
marier
il s'appelle omar ben laden vous faites
quoi je parle à ma fille alors vous êtes
contrôlés pendant le week-end sur une
route un v dont une voiture sympa je
vais pas la safrane d'autres comme ça
avec votre voiture
voilà les gendarmes vous contrôler il
inspecte la voiture et à ce moment là
votre pote votre votre à musique à côté
de vous vous avoue qu'il transporte un
kilo de cocaïne fait quoi quel con une
catastrophe c'est pas vrai c'est
dégoûtant merde il a eu la vache folle
ces valses javas gagne 2 crois que les
vrais bons l'argent qu'est ce qu'on fait
est que cette coquille ouvrage la
brûlure
alors je la jette dans le caniveau
c'est con le jour même du mariage de
votre fille vous tombez amoureux de son
fiancé omar ben laden complètent quoi
hein
fait deux malheureux 3,2 à votre fille
d'abord parce qu'elle pourra pas
l'épousé puis marc parce que vous aimez
pas le garçon non me sort ça peut
changer à tout non je sais comme je suis
je sais pas comment je serai dans 10 ou
20 ans chômage pendant alors chabat et
gérard darmon ce film va être un énorme
succès vous ne m'en voudrez pas de vous
faire une interview à nous porter de
catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
alain chabat
jour même de votre mariage
vous avez le coup de foudre pour une
autre c'est réciproque
vous faites quoi
oh
compliqué c'est compliqué je suis très
lâche je dis oui mon amour ma fille ce
faire
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une catastrophe
donc le jour du mariage coup de foudre
pour une autre série 6-3 vous faites
quoi c'est pas ça vous est déjà arrivé
peut-être en fait jour merci de m'aider
je sais pas je pense que moi j'aime bien
les choses quand elles arrivent alors je
sais pas si c'est une chose qui peut
être fait une médiatement je le fais
jouer après c'est vraiment un coup de
foudre placard oui ne change pas
alors vous êtes
en vacances avec toute votre famille
vous trouver seul avec votre belle mère
qui vous fait des avances
c'est d'après midi tout le monde est à
la mer vous êtes seul avec mamie givet
à bâle moi ce sans aucune hésitation j'y
vais aussi malvenue alors que c'est bon
à savoir
oui votre femme
dans ce cas là tous les chiffres du loto
mais vous avez oublié de valider le
bulletin ah ouais on lui dit que ça
comment
moi je dis gagner du temps ouais c'est
ça qui est important comme ça c'est
gagner du temps ils viennent y ai dit
qu'est ce que vous faites plus comment
faire
je lui dit donne moi le
le biais culturel que tu a coché les
noms c'est toi qui n'as jamais bien tu
comprends pourquoi ne s'est jamais
mariée c'est tout alors vous avez
draguer une nana super vraiment super ça
c'est vrai je suis témoin vous la
ramenez chez vous vous découvrez que
c'est un travesti vous réagissez comme
ans avait pas arrivé mais
pourquoi pas contre le peuple ok je la
refais oui ça m'est arrivé début mai
pas de problème il faut aimer les femmes
avec des grands hôpitaux rythme je suis
dopé m
est ce que votre père regarde l'émission
là dans leurs voiles à l'espagne aussi
des gros mots et quand je me moque des
faibles
voilà la raison il a raison à mort
reçues la raison est un gros clitoris
est pas un gros mot
c'est donc ça passera voilà c'est même
un nom égyptiens gros clitoris
donc ça reste dans ma mission cléopâtre
c'est la promo voilà bien fait de la
prononce pas
ouais mon père pour moi il est je suis
toujours à l'école comment ça va bien
claude berri il est content de ton
travail car lescure il trouve que tu
travailles bien oui
mais c'est mon fan numéro 000 et quand
même c'est lui que j'ai vu a perdu
reprise directement avec le père de
farruggia way avec le papa de sa route
alors attention interview catastrophe
contrôle de routine sur la route pendant
que les flics inspectent le véhicule
votre pote était assis à côté de vous
vous avoue qu'il transporte 1 kg de
cocaïne dans son sac
vous l'avez pas dit bien sûr mais sur
fait quoi
le couvent mais après on partage
ça s'est pas passé comme ça je sais qu
est ce que je fais aurait dit ok mais
d'un coup il a fait un film derrière
de quoi c'est à dire quoi que j'ai pas
compris dans une bagnole oui d'accord là
je comprends le pote avec qui vous êtes
je suis aussi au moment où les flics
arrivent
j'ai un kg de coke dans le sac oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait faites quoi vous me
dites à tête est un gros con va essayer
de s'en sortir
1 on essaie de 2,2 passes et ce en tête
après voilà donc
ce jour là j'ai fait l'apologie ça
pourrait vraiment pour la banane ou bien
si votre fils vous annonce qu'il va se
marier
88e et un bond de toujours citer de
l'esprit oui la jeune fille s'appelle
ben laden à munichois vasini que la
musique est hélas
pour sauver la population d'une ville
vous êtes bruce willis pour sauver la
population d'une ville je vais faire
sauter un train yes
si votre femme et vos enfants sont à
bord alors
fait quoi désolé pour les villes ça va
pas être possible ma santé me désole
alain chabat interview catastrophe
vous partez en vacances à l'île maurice
allais rigolote salaire est bien
difficile
le 30 janvier
ah non question de la fiche numéro 69
arrêter tous les rôles sont inversés
c'est vous arrive comme ça qu'ils
allaient me poser une question
alors qu'est-ce que vous n'aimeriez pas
entendre venant de la bouche d'une femme
que j'ai une petite [ __ ]
on était
cela me pose des questions je n'arrive
pas à ne pas y répondre
c'est un drôle donc interview
catastrophe gilles godrèche le jour même
de votre mariage vous avez un coup de
foudre pour un autre et c'est réciproque
vous faites quoi moi je le fais
en fait quoi la chose avec le nouveau
oui c'est bien votre est un peu comme ça
boehner veut pas dire être le mariage
c'est tout je pense que je vais être
invité au mariage de sécurité bien sûr
alors pendant les vacances en famille
vous vous retrouvez seul avec votre
beau-père qui se met en mouvement
ah bon les vacances en famille on
trouvait seul avec votre belle-mère qui
se met à vous faire découvrir vos
lettres inverse venir se met à vous
faire des avances vous vous en sortez
comment mais je le fais avec
tony nous annonce qu'il a tous les
chiffres du loto mais vous vous avez
oublié de valider le ticket que faites
vous alors là on dit tant mieux avant ah
ouais mais le pauvre il avait tout le
loto dans l'ordre mais vous identifier
pas comme ça terrible et où aucune
culpabilité non non mais je sais pas si
des dés les gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent au loto
ça leur change rien ça va pas bien c'est
bon c'est pas vrai c'est mauvais vous
avez craqué sur un mec superbe et au
moment de passer à l'acte vous découvrez
que c'est une fille ça vient comme ça le
fait rire là je pense que ça lui
rappelle des trucs
sinon vous réagissez comme on
sérieusement ça ne dérange pas ça vous
dérange pas très bien alors contrôle de
routine sur l'autoroute justement
pendant que les flics inspecte des
véhicules votre pote votre meilleure
amie assise à côté de vous vous avoue
qu'il transporte 1 kg de cocaïne dans le
coffre
ah ouais ouais
il vous l'a pas dit ce connard moment il
ya l'effet que vous le faites quoi
marien seule classe quoi maria ne
trouvez pas un subterfuge pour détourner
l'attention des policiers mais toute nue
je me met à danser les trucs comme ça
voilà c'est bien c'est pas 2 1 pour vous
la poussez dans une correction ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux